MELISSA ECCLES: We thought to
ourselves, how can we reinvent
the shopping process?
How can we reinvent the
experience that people are
having when they try
to buy a new car?
How does everybody look
into their car?
They go to the manufacturer's
website.
They start to investigate.
And maybe if they get far enough
along in the process,
they decide that they want
to configure a car.
BO GUSTAVVSON: Seeing how many
different options you had for
this car, and you could go
through this computer.
We had about 500 different
videos that we could piece
together in many versions.
MEGAN BETTOR: In essence, we
wanted it to feel like one
extended performance, theatrical
performance.
MELISSA ECCLES: And we wanted
to do this in a way and on a
platform where our target
already was.
And that platform was YouTube.
We've got a longstanding
30-year-plus relationship with
our client.
And they said, all right, if
this is what your consumer
insights are telling you, if
this is where your users are,
then we're willing to take
that risk with you.
And it paid off with the
time of engagement.
We had people spending about 22
minutes in the experience.
BRIAN MOROZ: Whoa!
MELISSA ECCLES: One
team, one dream.
It sounds cheesy,
but it's true.
And everybody really believed
that we were doing something
innovative and something
groundbreaking.
So It's easy for people to
collaborate when they're
really excited about the idea
they're collaborating on.